The trailer for Olaf's Frozen Adventure just
dropped and gives us a cool sneak peek at
the new Disney animated mini-movie starring
Frozen's snowman.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and I'm excited to see that while we wait
for Frozen 2, Disney will be treating us to
a 21-minute short film or featurette that
brings back for a holiday special all our
favourite Frozen characters including Elsa,
Anna, Kristoff, Sven and Olaf.
So, in this video, I'm going to be analysing
the new trailer and revealing some cool Frozen
and Disney easter eggs plus some other little
details you might have missed.
When the Frozen filmmaking team began dreaming
up stories for the first Frozen-themed short
film, Frozen Fever, many of their initial
ideas actually focused on Olaf the snowman!
Of course, in the end, they turned their attention
to Elsa and Anna instead, but, as is clear
from the title and trailer for Olaf's Frozen
Adventure, the filmmaking team have decided
to put the friendly snowman very much at the
front-and-centre of their storytelling again!
Speaking of Frozen Fever, there are some nice
little parallels between that short and this
new one.
For example, both stories centre on family
celebrations and traditions, with Frozen Fever
being all about birthday festivities while
Olaf's Frozen Adventure is all about the holiday
season; in fact, in this new short film, Elsa
and her sister will be celebrating this particular
holiday for the first time since they were
reunited.
Also, both short films feature characters
on the hunt for something around Arendelle:
in Frozen Fever, Elsa sent her sister on a
scavenger hunt for birthday gifts, while this
new film sees Olaf on the hunt for holiday
traditions so he can celebrate the season
with Elsa and her sister who were apart so
long that they don't have any family traditions
of their own.
By the way, on the subject of family, the
family portrait we see in the trailer is actually
an original piece of concept art for the movie
Frozen.
During Olaf's adventure, we see him enjoying
finding out about the different ways families
mark the holidays.
And there's a very funny easter egg for Wreck-It
Ralph when he grabs a candy cane and uses
it to replace his carrot nose, exclaiming
"Sugar Rush!"
In the first Wreck-It Ralph movie, Ralph enters
a go-kart racing candy-filled game called
Sugar Rush which features a Candy Cane Forest
where he meets Vanellope.
Wreck-It-Ralph 2 is actually Disney's next
animated movie so it's cool that they added
a little nod to it here, as they also did
in Moana.
There's a touch of adult humour in this moment
as well as the way Olaf's eyes spin reminded
me of the reaction of the main characters
in animated movies like Pinocchio and The
Good Dinosaur when they got rather different
rushes.
One of the festive traditions that Olaf learns
about in the scene you can see here is the
feast of Saint Lucia, which in a number of
Nordic countries, like the ones that inspired
the Frozen movies, is celebrated on 13th December,
and includes a girl typically wearing a white
gown and red sash together with a wreath of
candles on her head.
And, as you can see from his sleigh, Olaf
collects quite a few gifts on his travels
with Sven.
And hidden in this shot of the sleigh, there's
a green toy with a little tuft of reddish-pink
hair which could be a nod to Elliot from Pete's
Dragon.
And you can also just make out what looks
like a Troll, which is call-back to the Trolls
in the original Frozen movie and the Troll
statues outside Oaken's store.
And it looks like Olaf will be paying a visit
to Oaken's sauna in this short film too, which
makes sense as, although it's a different
season here, we know from Olaf's 'In Summer'
song that he likes the idea of 'lettin' off
steam'!
In fact, Olaf's Frozen Adventure doesn't just
link very nicely back to Disney's previous
Frozen tales, but, according to John Lasseter,
who's Chief Creative Officer at Disney and
Pixar Animation Studios, it also "fits in
perfectly with Frozen 2", which is due out
in cinemas in November 2019.
Indeed, as Lasseter told EW, 'you could sit
down and watch Olaf's Frozen Adventure and
Frozen 2 as one big marathon.'
Which makes it sound like this latest tale
really is part of the building blocks for
the much-anticipated Frozen sequel, which
will follow the lives of Elsa and her sister
after the events of this new short.
Of course, one of the mega-popular parts of
the Frozen movies are their insanely catchy
songs.
For Frozen and Frozen Fever, those tunes were
written by husband-and-wife team Robert Lopez
and Kristen Anderson-Lopez.
This time though, there's a new song-writing
duo in the kingdom: Kate Anderson and Elyssa
Samsel, and they've written four original
songs for the new mini-movie.
And, in case you're wondering, the track you
hear in the trailer is called 'When We're
Together', and notice how, as the sisters
sing the song, Elsa seems to be sending Olaf
up into the air with a star that has a mini-snowman
figure frozen inside it.
And did Olaf put the same star on top of the
Christmas tree here?
By the way, the look of the tree and the snowflake
shape underneath makes me think that Elsa
has fashioned this tree herself out of ice,
in a similar way to how she made an ice sculpture
for her sister's birthday in Frozen Fever.
Although Olaf's Frozen Adventure was initially
going to make its debut on TV, now it's going
to premiere on the big screen in front of
Pixar's animated movie, Coco, in a similar
way to how the short film Frozen Fever first
screened in front of Disney's live-action
movie Cinderella.
And it's interesting that both Olaf's Frozen
Adventure and Coco share a common theme of
family traditions centred around big celebrations,
with Olaf's Adventure focusing on the December
holidays and Coco on the Day of the Dead.
By the way, to find out lots more about Coco,
hit the top-right of the screen to watch my
video on Pixar's new movie.
Now, how excited are you for Olaf's Frozen
Adventure?
And what would you like to see happen in Frozen
2?
Let me know in the comments below!
And if you enjoyed this, do please hit that
like button and tap the screen to check out
more of my other Disney animation videos,
including cool facts you might not know about
Frozen Fever.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!